so this joe biden guy uh he is uh i
guess the president of the united states
and uh the official white house
uh twitter account tweeted this out
right before july 4th it's just
quite extraordinary uh planning a
cookout this year
ketchup on the news according to the
farm bureau
the cost of a fourth of july bbq is down
from last year
it's a fact you must herd
hot dog the biden economic plan is
working
and that's something we can all relish
okay i'm not above a bad pun you know it
right like i like a bad pun actually
okay um but this is horrible this is
just horrible
and if you look at the image can we put
the image up again for just a sec uh if
you put the image up
uh what they do there they had a gif and
it was flicking through some of the
things and you'd save four cents on this
and five cents on this
the cumulative amount of savings that
they are bragging about
on the official white house twitter
account
from year to year on a july 4th bbq is
16
cents and someone at the white house got
that information
mr president we've uh crunched the
numbers here uh i used the calculator we
carried the one
and according to this year we've got
great news the economic numbers are in
the average family is going to save 16
cents on their july 4th barbecue and
then someone at the white house
right because it wasn't joe someone at
the white house said tweet that
out tweet out to the good people
that they are going to save 16 cents do
we have 16 cents here either one of you
have changed i haven't had a change in
my pocket
if god knows how long i wish i had a
dime a nickel and a penny
just like just to visually in case you
really can't think with 16 senses we do
everything digitally now
this is so profoundly ridiculous and
it's so
it's so consistent with just how awful
these people are
like everything they say is either a lie
or a manipulation
of truth or they're like
how somebody you know what
i try not to do it that often but again
i i will go in the comments
of youtube today i will spend a few
minutes with my team after the show
today
i always go into locals i respond to
people but i'm so struck
by this epic load of [ __ ] that the
white house put out
that i will go into the youtube comment
section the most evil place
in the history of the world okay i will
go in there and i want somebody to
explain to me what i'm missing here
how did this happen how did somebody in
the administration say yes this is a
good idea 16 cents
even if you had saved 250 it wouldn't
have been a good idea
six dollars it would have been a good
idea relative to the amount of people
that they have caused to be laid off
with lockdowns and put on unemployment
and everything else so no the biden
economic plan
is not working do you think it's working
like do you person think did anyone
i saved 16 cents let's buy a house
me and the little lady we're gonna get a
home loan and like come on
jesus